I did see it coming but of course like
I'm sad about it like I mean sometimes
it just doesn't work out they're not
happy they're not in love Cody and
Christine's kids giving their honest
opinion about their parents splitting up
on the latest episode of Sister Wives I
cannot get out from under this cloud of
sadness
and it's because of the Nuance of of a
breakup I'm trying to be a husband a
father to their children a lover to two
people who may not see eye to eye that's
a real challenge the family comes
together to celebrate Isabelle's
birthday and graduation the first
Gathering since Christine dropped the
bombshell she's leaving Cody After 26
years together I also wanted them to
know
that this might be one of the last times
we get together
Christine has told us that she's leaving
Cody for good so I'm a little bit
nervous because I'm like okay are we
going to be able to be around each other
and be normal and natural and
comfortable or is it going to be tense
but things aren't uncomfortable for
Isabelle I think with my mom and my dad
getting a divorce if I'm honest I did
see it coming but of course like I'm sad
about it like I mean sometimes it just
doesn't work out and I'm happy that my
mom will be able to find somebody who
she's really really really happy with as
for their other daughter mckelty and her
husband Tony they're on phase two I was
honestly relieved when I heard my mom
was leaving my dad they're not happy
they're not in love
I thought it was a little inevitable I
can't imagine any man being perfect
enough to be able to handle four wives
there's five of us very five different
thinking adults who are trying to raise
kids together and have a family together
and we don't see eye to eye on all
things but Cody's still struggling to
adjust to this new normal I've got what
feels like very strained relationships
with a bunch of the kids I'm not in a
good place with everybody and it's not
that I'm trying to be angry or trying to
hold them accountable in this moment or
anything like that I don't feel like
I've got the respect that I should have
I'm here I'm in a funk it's a kind of a
this
loneliness
combined with a bitterness with the
entire family that said though the party
turns out to be a success as the wives
and Cody put a strong front on for their
kids we kind of jumped right back to
where we were before the thing the covet
hit back rejects very family again
which is really nice I'm living in a
delusional world where I'm wishing that
Christine wouldn't leave I'm struggling
with
sort of a state of regret and
frustration
for me that is that is my life
and I'm kind of bearing my guts and I
know I feel like my job is to be
truthful and as kind as I can be while
being truthful I think the experience is
a very deep emotional Challenge and and
and uh and I could smile about it
because I'm having a lot of fun I'm
working with my family I I really enjoy
what I do
but I'm a flawed individual and it's not
fun to see that
[Music]